continúa el intercambio de bombardeo sin
precedentes entre israel y gaza según el
ejército israelí hamas y la yihad
islámica han lanzado más de 1600 cohetes
repelidos en su mayoría por un sistema
antimisiles desde el lunes van al menos
90 muertos en los dos frentes de la vida
anuncia despliegue masivo de fuerzas de
seguridad
colombia vivió una nueva jornada de paro
nacional contra el gobierno las
manifestaciones se tornaron pacíficas y
masivas durante el día pero al caer la
noche en varios puntos de la capital y
el norte del país se registraron
disturbios el ejecutivo trata de ceder
en algunas de las demandas para calmar
el descontento social
los chilenos acuden este fin de semana a
las urnas para elegir a los 155
candidatos
que redactarán la nueva constitución son
las elecciones más importantes desde el
plebiscito que marcó el fin de la
dictadura de augusto pinochet 17 de los
escaños están por primera vez
representados a los diez pueblos
originarios que existen en chile
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 si re blanco como
siempre un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos
a este informativo con el
recrudecimiento de las hostilidades
entre israel y palestina' una nueva
noche de intentos de intensos bombardeos
vivieron ambos lados la peor escalada de
violencia en los últimos siete años que
ha dejado desde el lunes al menos 90
muertos en su mayoría palestinos el
gobierno israelí anunció un despliegue
masivo de fuerzas de seguridad
terrestres para frenar los
enfrentamientos entre los barrios judíos
y árabes
es la peor crisis desde 2014
las explosiones no cesan el ejército
israelí bombardea la franja de gaza
donde ha matado a decenas de civiles y
al líderes de hamás este grupo responde
con cohetes y también deja víctimas
mortales en israel según el ejército
israelí desde la franja de gaza se han
enviado 1.600 cohetes muchos de ellos
han sido interceptados por la defensa
antimisiles de israel
hay momentos terroríficos por ejemplo
cuando vi salir a un padre con sus hijos
de un apartamento oscuro con una
linterna en la cabeza porque un misil
impactó en una casa encima de la suya es
terrible anoche y dejó la víctima mente
se conocida una escalada entre dos
fuerzas desiguales en gaza- las
limitaciones a la circulación y a los
servicios básicos impuestas por israel
son la norma para los palestinos human
right watch acusó a tel aviv por el
apartheid que ejerce sobre la población
palestina el escenario en gaza es el de
edificios pulverizados como la torre al
shurouq que albergaba una cadena de
televisión creada por hamás el ejército
de israel también asaltó una oficina de
inteligencia de la organización
islamista de noche en el hospital las
ambulancias no paran de llegar a los
foros estaba delante de una tienda y de
repente un misil cayó sobre nosotros no
a todos personas se causó ocho heridos
estaba sentado dentro de la tienda y
otros estaban en la casa cuando vimos el
estruendo de los bombardeos después
perdí el conocimiento no me acuerdo de
nada
las tensiones pueden aumentar israel
anunció el despliegue masivo de fuerzas
militares y jamás se declara listo para
resistir
y ante esta escalada de hostilidades el
consejo de seguridad de la onu guarda
silencio sobre el conflicto entre el
ejército israelí y las milicias
palestinas mientras tanto el presidente
estadounidense joe biden habló con el
primer ministro israelí benjamín
netanyahu envió al secretario de estado
adjunto a la región para buscar vías de
entendimiento entre los líderes de ambas
partes
bailén aseguró que tiene esperanza en
que la situación se resuelva lo más
rápido posible pero fue enfático en que
israel tiene derecho a defenderse cuando
miles de misiles son disparados hacia su
territorio escuchamos ahora parte de las
declaraciones del presidente
estadounidense
mi expectativa y esperanza es que esto
termine más temprano que tarde pero
israel tiene derecho a defenderse de los
cohetes lanzados hacia su territorio
y hacemos análisis de lo que ocurre
entre israel y palestina' nos acompaña
así van gogh orígenes periodista y
vicepresidenta de la comunidad chilena
en israel gracias por acompañarnos el
día de hoy
pregunto cuáles y cuántos factores han
desencadenado este nuevo enfrentamiento
entre israel y palestina
mira muchas gracias primero por la
invitación
perdón que estoy con mis hijos en casas
los niños están si no te preocupes si
acabamos de subir del refugio acaba de
sonar la sirena donde estoy hace 20
minutos así que están un poco
pasados okay así que los niños se
asustan no hay mucho que hacer con eso
pero como para contestar tu pregunta hay
varios factores para definir qué es lo
que está pasando acá primero tenemos una
contextualización dentro de la política
palestina tenemos a mahmud abás que te
había llamado elecciones y las canceló
esos en estas que los palestinos llevan
16 años sin elecciones lo que enojó
mucho a hamás que son los que gobiernan
en la franja de gaza y tienen disputa
pone a vásquez de la autoridad nacional
palestina ellos dijeron que se
cancelaban las elecciones jerusalén y
barber esto se está usando como una
excusa política interna de ellos por
otra parte tenemos las exacerbaciones
del mes de ramadán donde tenemos células
extremistas de musulmanes dentro de los
feligreses que están rezando todos los
días en la ciudad vieja de jerusalén que
también llamaron la violencia le pegaron
a gente intentaron linchar y tenemos sea
todo un contexto que se empezó a
difundir en diferentes focos que llevó a
que jamás
subiera la cantidad de misiles que hasta
como ustedes dijeron el día de hoy
después de casi tres días de escalada
llegaron a 1600 ahora si van qué papel
está jugando entonces este movimiento
islamista hamás que gobierna la franja
de gaza además al fatah de mahmud abás y
la autoridad palestina
o sea que es totalmente un 'tira y
afloja' como se dice jamás es el que
está intentando manejar todo a su manera
y tratando de manipular los hechos
presionando israel con misiles que
llegan hasta tel aviv hasta jerusalén
hace dos días atrás tienen misiles de la
franja de gaza y jerusalén hay 100
kilómetros de la franja de gaza donde
estoy yo hay 80 kilómetros o sea no
estamos hablando de piedritas estamos
hablando de misiles de alto alcance el
otro día ayer fue dos misiles
antitanques se dispararon desde gaza
hacia israel uno de ellos impactó en un
auto también matando a dos personas esto
esto un tira y afloje pero israel no va
a permitir que se ataque a su población
civil con mil 600 misiles ahora ustedes
mostraron ante las imágenes que se
derrumbó un edificio en casa israel está
bombardeando blancos estratégicos de
hamás ustedes también lo explicaron que
lo que estás buscando deshabilitar al
grupo terrorista porque hamás es un
grupo terrorista islamista
el objetivo del ejército israel nunca
van a ser los civiles jamás si o sea
dentro de los muertos de israel hay
árabes también que viven dentro de
israel entonces hamas no le importa
donde caen los misiles es lo que hay que
entender también que israel avisa dentro
del territorio de hamás cuando va a
bombardear para desalojar si van
hablemos ahora del primer ministro
benjamin netanyahu y cómo quedan sus
fuerzas después de este nuevo estallido
de la violencia
gran detallado estar una posición ahora
estamos justo en la mitad de formación
de gobierno información de coalición la
gente que no se olvide que pasamos
elecciones y en detalle o no pudo formar
coalición no pudo llegar a los 61
mandatos que necesita para hacer un
nuevo gobierno y lo estaban invitando a
ser ahora sus contrincantes y a ir
rápido conjunto con neftalí benet que
estaban formando intentando formar un
gobierno pero el comité de seguridad de
israel sigue funcionando y lápiz derecho
es parte del benny gantz es ministro de
defensa que también es en contrario
netania o entonces él tiene que seguir
funcionando y tiene que seguir llevando
al país a una situación lo más segura
posible ahora si van es evidente que
existen las rivalidades y ha pasado
durante años pero le pregunto si podría
haber ese entonces algún tipo de
reconciliación ante tanta violencia
la reconciliación entre israelíes y
palestinos
digamos algún tipo de acuerdo entre
entre israel y palestina para que paren
estas hostilidades para que para los
enfrentamientos para que no siga
sufriendo la población civil
si jamás deja de bombardear a él se
retira
graciasivan por su tiempo por estar aquí
con nosotros en france 24 que tenga
usted felices todavía y cuídense mucho
vamos ahora hasta colombia donde las
manifestaciones en contra del gobierno
del presidente van tú que no cesan luego
de más de dos semanas de protestas
ciudadanas ayer durante el día las
marchas fueron masivas y pacíficas pero
durante la noche se registraron algunos
enfrentamientos en bogotá la capital del
país donde las fuerzas donde las afueras
del congreso hubo enfrentamientos entre
algunos manifestantes y la policía
antidisturbios situación similar se
vivió en la ciudad de barranquilla en el
norte de colombia y en cali epicentro de
este descontento social entre tanto
avanza el diálogo propuesto por el
gobierno para contener estas protestas
en su contra y aunque el presidente iván
duque se ha reunido con varios sectores
sociales los manifestantes que lideran
las protestas rechazan las
conversaciones por señalar que no se les
tiene en cuenta asimismo desde bogotá el
comité nacional del paro niega que
existan las bases para sentarse a
negociar con el ejecutivo
reclaman una voz real en el diálogo tras
dos semanas de protestas contra su
gobierno del presidente colombiano iván
duque inició conversaciones con
representantes de varios sectores
sociales aunque los manifestantes
denuncian que siguen siendo ignorados
que están haciéndose un juego con el
pueblo colombiano no quieren escuchar lo
que es las peticiones del pueblo que ya
nos cansamos de la ave rancia del estado
colombiano que lo único que hacen mal
tratarnos y agredirnos con balas con
disparos con gases con cárcel con
muertes y con desapariciones desde el
comité nacional del paro aseguran
asimismo que no hay condiciones de
negociación le hemos solicitado el
comité de paro al presidente como
comandante de las fuerzas armadas que
pare la masacre que hay contra los
jóvenes en colombia que desmilitariza la
protesta social que no permita el uso de
armas letales en la protesta social por
parte del esmad
sin estas condiciones sin garantías es
imposible negociar el pliego de
emergencia que le presentamos hace un
año al presidente
remarcan también que los motivos de la
protesta siguen existiendo 17 millones
de personas que se acuestan con hambre
21 millones de personas que es el 40 por
ciento de la población en pobreza
cerca del 10% de la población en extrema
pobreza que gana menos de un dólar y
medio diario otros señalan avances una
cosa importante en la visita del
presidente ayer y es que escucho que
escucho a la gente que estuvo con él
pidiéndole que esto no sea una solución
armada sino de diálogo
que acepto ayer mismo empezar la misa de
negociación pero en cali epicentro de
las protestas los manifestantes exigen
que el viernes el presidente y los
gobiernos locales acudan en persona a
escucharlos por primera vez
y ahora vamos al sur de nuestro
continente el próximo fin de semana los
chilenos acudirán a votar para elegir
entre otros a los ciento cincuenta y
cinco candidatos encargados de elaborar
una nueva constitución que reemplace a
la actual una de las herencias de la
dictadura de augusto pinochet 17 de esos
escaños están por primera vez en su
historia reservados a los diez pueblos
originarios que existen en chile
seguimos la campaña de una de las
candidatas a constituyente por el pueblo
mapuche el mayoritario en el país
nuestra corresponsal patricia luna nos
trae el informe
elisa loncón lleva toda su vida
defendiendo y enseñando el mapudungun la
lengua del pueblo originario mayoritario
en chile los mapuches que representan el
10 por ciento de la población chilena
representa ser una política genocida
lingüística está matando nuestra tengo
original
aquí presenta un recurso ante el
ministerio de educación tras que se
publicara un decreto que convierte el
mapudungún en una asignatura optativa y
no obligatoria como hasta ahora para los
niños mapuches la la lengua indígena son
parte de los derechos humanos
fundamentales defensora de su lengua y
líder social elisa es una de los 39
candidatos mapuches que opta a uno de
los 17 escaños reservados a pueblos
originarios de los 155 disponibles para
escribir una nueva constitución en chile
nuestro interés es llegar a la
constitución es en pos de esa justicia
histórica pero al mismo tiempo de
nuestras contribuciones como naciones
originarias buscan la plurinacionalidad
y la nueva constitución chilena
aportando su visión de la naturaleza
para dejar atrás un modelo neoliberal
donde el agua y los territorios han sido
muchas veces privatizados aunque 17
escaños no les parece suficientes por
primera vez en la historia podrán votar
por sus propios representantes
yo estoy esperanzada este es un sueño es
un sueño del pueblo mapuche que yo
escuché desde pequeña y que bueno en el
tiempo que llevo de vida también lo he
acariciado y lo he vuelto a soñar y yo
creo que algo alcanzaremos en esta en
este primer intento de tener los escaños
reservados un sueño para un pueblo que
necesita aún justicia llegar al siglo 21
para por primera vez en muchos siglos
ser reconocidos como parte de la
institucionalidad
y de esa manera llegamos al final de la
informativa en france 24 continúa con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias buen día
[Música]
franz meeting